[Music]
hello everyone
welcome to talk to you the cloud for
our second season
my name is johan lucas and i am a
technical account manager within
the professional entity 6
big club organizations
in this episode we will demonstrate  how to
configure and monitor the costs
associated with the resources of our
environment on google cloud platform
when the fantastic knitting
had its own infrastructure
it was very easy to predict the
operational cost of their web servers their
databases or even the storage
necessary to host all the
images shared by his community
the servers or disks had been purchased
in advance and the return on
investment was very easy to
calculate what comes with its lot
more but also disadvantages when
deciding to migrate to google cloud
platform
it's quite a model  of capital
expenditure which is transformed into
operational expenditure,
in other words we  pays every month
for what we consume and no longer
once in advance for the infrastructure
that we have procured so
what are the advantages of this model
quite simply
if you ever install a
centerra byte hard drive but you
only use 50
so there are 50 data parrots that
have been paid for but are not
used in the same way for
virtual machines you may have
invested in
relatively high specs to plan for
increased traffic
however those specs are  very
little used for several months
this leads to a certain waste of
resources which turns into
useless expenses but suddenly what are the
disadvantages of this model and on the
other hand it becomes more difficult to
predict in advance how much the service will
cost when we were previously
limited by our resources in terms of
memory or cpu storage
now these limitations no longer exist
c  ar the environment is fully
scalable, it therefore becomes important to
set up a certain
monitoring mechanism to limit potential
uncontrolled expenses
to be controlled in the sense that certain
expenses can sometimes be generated
by external factors, for
example website abuse.  false manipulation
by the administrator or even
hacking attempts such as crypto
jacking this is why it is
important to have the necessary tools
to keep an eye on your expenses in
real time before launching into the
console  admin
I just wanted to do a little
recap on
how invoicing works on google cloud platform
whether it's for a start up or for
a multinational
you first need to create
an invoicing account this account
will then allow you to  link one of your
cloud projects within which you
can provision your resources to
summarize and with a c animation  This
time we will have the billing account
that finances projects that
contain resources and now it will be
time to take a look at
these different
billing management tools within the
administration console  from google cloud
as billing and admin for the
fantastic knitting I will be able to have access
to all the billing modules
as an example in london the
navigation menu in the billing part
then relive it this page gives us
information on all  the projects that
are attached to our
billing accounts for example here is our
billing account the
fantastic knitting with 10 projects
linked to it if you are wondering how to link
a project to a billing tale
it only takes a few seconds
when creating a  'a project for
example I will go to the list of
projects click on new project and
within this interface
I will be able to link my pro  jet to my
adequate billing account
if we go back to the menu we can
click on budget
enders in this part we will be
able to create one or more budgets
for each of our
billing accounts or for each of our
projects then set up a
notification by  e-mail so
we are going to create a budget for
this demo we start by giving
our budget a name then we select
our billing account or the project
we are going to take the
fantastic knitting billing account because
I would like to be notified of the
combined expenses of  all the projects
linked to this account
we will then be able to either choose
a specific amount or select
the amount that was invoiced to us
last month as a benchmark once
our budget has been specified we will be
able to determine when the
administrators of the billing account
must be alerted
this is specified as a percentage of the
amount between and previously and we
we can set up several thresholds
for example at 50 90 and 100% of the budget
once saved the alerts
will arrive in the mailbox
of the billing count administrators
when these thresholds have been reached
it is important to note that these
alerts will not stop
the project resources they are only put in
place to do their thing for
information here is how an email looks like
received with all the
necessary information related to
billing accounts and the threshold that has been
reached beyond the proactive alerts
there  also has the possibility of
monitoring the expenses of your projects or
resources in a more visual way for
this we will go back to the menu
and click on report within this
interface you can see the evolution
of your expenses on a graph with the
possibility of playing on  several types
of filters
first we will be able to choose
the time interval that we
want to view by  mi the available options
i will select the last three
months
then we can group and our
graph by project by product or
because they have chosen are not
replicated in order to identify
spending trends for each
product over the last three months
like you  you can see
it as we change our
selection the graph updates
automatically once the grouping is
complete we can still filter
by other criteria such as projects,
products, resources or
the labels you have configured  on
your resources
this graph becomes very practical if you
ever need to make a
relatively simple analysis of the evolution of
costs within all the projects
present for a more detailed
or even more personalized analysis it is
also possible to export all the
data  billing sources to
do this, simply create the export from
billing export and c  choose the option
that is most appropriate either in
manual export in csv
jayson format via file export or an export
to our declared cloud data warehouse
then just link this data to
your favorite visualization tool and you're done
by luck  our community has already created
some full time on data studio that
you can reuse
here is an example with a
detailed presentation of all expenses in
relation to certain products for example
I will be able to do in-depth studies
on my expenses trust
in jean claude chicoine or even  cloud
storage
here is how to properly control your
costs within a cloud
platform environment and avoid unpleasant
surprises at the end of the month to close this
episode
do not hesitate to take a look
in the description of this video you
will find there  additional resources
to expand on what
you saw today
thank you for listening
and see you soon
[Musiq  eu]